Becoming a Background Actor, or “extra”
as they are more widely known, is a fairly
simple process that usually involves little
more than responding to an ad.
Depending on the scope of the project and
the kind of extras needed, this ad could appear
anywhere from a dedicated website to Craigslist-
we even found examples of casting directors
using Facebook and Twitter to round up extras
quickly in a pinch.
For the professional extra (and yes, these
are a thing), they may even have an agent
who helps them book gigs to sit, stand, or
walk in the background of some scene in a
movie for barely more than minimum wage in
some cases.
Of course, if they are a career extra, they
tend to be members of SAG-AFTRA and earn a
much more respectable amount, on the order
of around $175 per work day, plus more if
a given shoot lasts more than 8 hours, which
isn’t uncommon.
There are also a slew of other ways money
can be tacked on in a given day’s work,
like letting the filmmakers use your car in
a scene or maybe bringing your own needed
props, like a baby stroller.
Similarly, if you are required to smoke during
a scene, required to get a certain haircut
or wear a substantial amount of body makeup,
if there is a delay on a meal break, etc.,
you get additional pay bumps.
On top of this, if you have a special skill,
for example are good at tennis and a given
scene needs people competently playing tennis
in the background, you can expect a small
pay bump for this.
(For a full list of the many and surprisingly
specific ways you can get pay bumps, and exact
dollar amounts, do go read, as we did in all
its glory, SAG-AFTRA’s absolutely riveting
56 page “Handbook for Performers Working
as Background Actors.”)
Moving on from pay, it’s almost universally
true that the food provided on sets is amazing.
As one veteran extra, Dawn McHargue, noted
of the fare on the set of Iron Man 3- “We
had anything you could think of: the best
steak, shrimp, lobster and crab.
The buffet table, you couldn’t see the end
of it.”
That said, as in all things on the set, even
when the extras’ buffet table looks like
something from the most opulent of aristocratic
parties, the talent get the best food of all,
and an extra trying to eat from that table
is likely to get a swift, and occasionally
harsh, rebuke.
As for how easy or hard it is to get a gig
as an extra, if you’re patient and have
a flexible schedule, this doesn’t seem terribly
difficult from all accounts we’ve read.
What is difficult is getting enough work to
make a career out of it, though there are
a select few who’ve managed this.
For most, however, it tends to be more of
a hobby.
For others, they try to use it as a way to
break into the industry.
However, it’s noted that this almost universally
won’t get you far, other than the value
in getting to observe the film making process
up close and personal.
The most important thing about landing a gig
as an extra invariably is your look.
As such, good, representative photos are generally
needed when applying for a given gig, along
with your body measurements and the like.
As different productions have different requirements,
what look is being sought out can vary wildly.
That said, a running theme is that most films
and TV shows are looking for decidedly nondescript
looking people to fill out scenes.
The reasoning being, of course, that a person
who stands out in some significant way could
prove to be distracting.
Another thing that might get you passed over
as an extra for a certain scene is if you
happen to resemble one of the principal actors.
As one pro extra, Amy Rogers, stated “On
Homeland, you’ll never see them place anyone
near Claire Danes who has the same hair color
as her.”
Of course, if you’re an established extra
with a good reputation and you happen to resemble
a given lead actor in various body features
and the like, you may ultimately leverage
that to being used as a stand in- the people
who are used in place of an actor for the
purposes of setting up the scene.
The great thing about these gigs is that they
pay a lot better and, for example when talking
a TV show, if you do a good job might mean
a regular gig you can do for potentially several
years for a nice steady paycheck.
Going back to people who have a little more,
shall we say, “unique” look, a silver
lining of standing out is that you could potentially
still be a bit actor, as films and TV shows
are occasionally in need of people with a
specific “look”.
Of course, the problem here is that such casting
calls are seldom kind or tactful- they know
what they want, and they are looking for someone
who doesn’t mind unabashedly flaunting what
they’ve got in that way.
So, for example, if you’re extremely overweight
or grotesquely ugly by conventional standards,
the best advice of others in this position
is to grow very thick skin if you also want
to make it in the industry.
That said, while there are exceptions, this
doesn’t seem to be much of a problem for
the type of people who apply for these roles,
as one such individual, Jesse Heiman noted,
“I’m never going to be the prom king,
I’m not going to be the quarterback of the
football team, I’m the lovable loser…
Maybe you get on the underground over there,
or you get on the bus, and there’s some
strange person who you wouldn’t want to
talk to – I get to play that guy….
In this town, even if you’re being talked
about in a negative way, it’s better than
not being talked about at all.”
On the other end of the spectrum, contrary
to what you’d expect, being extremely attractive
won’t usually bolster your chances of scoring
a gig as an extra.
Again, they don’t want someone who will
distract the audience watching at home.
As with all things, there are exceptions to
this, of course.
For example, a scene in, say, a strip-club,
will likely feature a handful of very scantily
clad extras of the extremely attractive variety.
Again, the running theme here being horses
for courses.
Speaking of animals, this all brings us around
to what it’s actually like being an extra
on a set.
In a word- boring.
In three words- mind numbingly boring.
In six- mind numbingly boring and occasionally
degrading.
You see, among the lowest on the hierarchy
of a set is almost always the extras.
While, as ever, there are plenty of exceptions,
with the likes of George Clooney having a
reputation of doing his best to combat the
poor treatment of extras on set and otherwise
embodying the “good guy” persona, in the
general case you can expect to be treated
as disposable cattle most of the time.
In regards to the filming process itself,
extras, like children in a stereotypical British
household, are expected to be seen and not
heard.
Beyond it being strictly forbidden to talk
to the talent or distract them in any way,
even in off time, in order to keep the various
sounds in the film as isolated from other
noises as possible, the mics are usually targeted
at only recording the voices of the talent.
Virtually all background noises are then added
in post-production.
In addition to background chatter, this includes
noises you aren’t even expected to notice,
like the ruffling of the main character’s
clothes as they walk or the clink of a cup
being placed on a table.
This is generally one of the more difficult
things for extras to get good at as many people
find it unnatural to make silent vocalisations
without overcompensating by moving their eyebrows
too much or otherwise trying to use body language
to make up for the fact that they aren’t
making any noise when fake talking.
To avoid this, beyond being conscientious
of body movements, some extras practice nonsense
phrases they can repeatedly mouth to one another.
For a little fun, pay attention to talking
extras in the background next time you watch
a movie.
You can almost always spot the newbies from
the veteran pro extras because of things like
this.
On that note, because most sounds are added
in post-production, scenes involving parties,
dancing, or cheering crowds are an especially
surreal experience for extras, as the set
is almost always completely silent while filming,
other than the talent doing their thing.
This poses another unique challenge for extras
who are required to dance to a song they can’t
hear, in time with other people listening
to the same, non-existent song, all while
pretending to ignore whatever the main actors
are doing.
And with cheering crowds, extras must be extremely
careful not to actually make any clapping
noises while they clap and otherwise raucously
cheer silently.
For those attached to their phones, it should
be noted that smartphones and other such devices
are largely banned from TV and movie sets,
at least when talking about extras.
Extras also are generally required to sign
non-disclosure agreements right off the bat,
barring them from talking about what they
saw on the set at all, particularly on social
media.
Ironically enough, that means this was almost
literally the first rule on the set of Fight
Club.
It’s also important to note here that a
given shoot might easily last 10-15+ hours,
during which the extras are mostly to be found
waiting around for someone to tell them what
to do.
This could mean sitting or standing quietly,
sometimes for hours at a time, and, at best,
whispering with other extras, or in many cases
required to keep completely silent.
When not required to be in a given place,
extras generally congregate in some designated
area away from the important people, where
they read, chat, play cards, or otherwise
find any way possible to stave off boredom.
Beyond being boring, in some cases the life
of an extra can also be extremely uncomfortable.
For example, if a scene is supposed to be
in the winter, but it’s actually the summer
and 100 degrees outside in balmy southern
California, they’ll nonetheless require
you to wear appropriate winter clothing and
jackets for outdoor scenes, and vice versa
in the winter when a scene is supposed to
be in the summer.
Speaking of clothing, while certainly period
pieces with large budgets may provide the
necessary wardrobe, in most cases extras are
required to bring their own clothing appropriate
for a given scene.
A savvy veteran extra may even bring a suitcase
with a variety of clothing just to make sure
they have exactly what’s needed to get in
a given scene
Going back to the general case, extras are
usually expected to wear mostly unremarkable
clothing featuring muted colors that won’t
stand out on camera.
Also important here is that the clothing must
be devoid of visible logos or branding.
This is mostly due to the fact that showing
brands or logos on screen usually requires
someone, somewhere to sign off on them appearing
on screen, but can sometimes be because the
production has a deal with a specific brand
or manufacturer.
To maintain continuity between shots, extras
could, and in most cases will, be expected
to wear the exact same outfit multiple days
in a row if a scene takes multiple days to
shoot, with some directors going as far as
to have pictures taken of individual extras
to ensure their outfit and hair remains the
exact same between takes.
In the end, if you don’t mind crappy pay,
uncertain and irregular work schedule, long
hours of mind numbing boredom, repetitively
doing the same thing over and over and over
again, and generally being treated like something
the directors found stuck on the bottom of
their shoes, you too can enjoy the benefits
of amazing catering and potentially being
barely visible in the background of a given
scene of a movie for a few seconds.
Or, if you’re really lucky, as one Jon Porter
noted of the pinnacle of his Background Acting
career, in which he got to play a dead German
soldier who the protagonist of the film had
killed,
It’s inevitably the stunt guys who have
the fun of actually getting into a fight.
The moment they die, however, it becomes the
humble extra’s job to lie on the ground
and play their corpse for the rest of the
shots in the scene.
So that’s what I did for two weeks of my
life.
I [laid] on the ground, outside, in the middle
of February playing a corpse in a major motion
picture.
It was simultaneously the least and the most
glamorous thing I’ve ever done in my life.
Still, we guess there are worse ways to spend
an afternoon than eating phenomenal, free
food while occasionally catching a distant
glimpse of Ryan
Reynolds
who is, of course, dreamy.
Because of the high price of paying a crowd
of thousands of extras, for most films and
TV shows where such is required, these are
almost always digitized audiences or a group
of extras shot such that they can be overlayed
to fill out a stadium.
Cardboard cutouts are also commonly used interspersed
with real people, though tend to stand out
if the camera is moved during the shot.
For these cases, another option available
for the director wanting something particularly
realistic looking are inflatable extras which,
yes, are a thing and if you watch closely
can be occasionally spotted interspersed with
real people
in crowd scenes.